rebel wilson is responding to reports
that she was forced to expose her
relationship just days after revealing
she has a girlfriend
on thursday rebel shared this photo of
herself smiling ear to ear with ramona
agruma on instagram the caption i
thought i was searching for a disney
prince but maybe what i really needed
all this time was a disney princess
hashtag love is love it's like love is
in the air but turns out allegedly it
wasn't rebel's choice to reveal her new
romance on saturday the sydney morning
herald published an opinion piece which
has since been taken down by journalist
andrew hornery in the article hornery
writes that they gave rebel a two-day
deadline to provide a comment about her
relationship before they plan to
announce it themselves but rebel chose
not to participate which hornery writes
about in the op-ed quote wilson opted to
gazump the story posting about her new
disney princess
rebels fans they immediately spoke out
on social media criticizing the
newspaper for allegedly forcing the star
to reveal something so personal among
the critics journalist kate doak who
tweeted about the situation and tagged
rebel the actress saw it and decided to
respond hinting that it wasn't exactly
her choice to go public she writes
thanks for your comments it was a very
hard situation but trying to handle it
with grace
but on sunday a herald editor released a
statement denying outing rebel instead
they say they only asked if she wished
to comment about her new partner we
would have asked the same questions had
wilson's new partner been a man to say
that the herald outed wilson is wrong
as for rebel's love story a source tells
e.t the funny gal and ramona are very
happy together their friends are so
supportive of their relationship and
thrilled for them it's amazing
and rebel is all about living her best
life telling e.t last month how she's
doing just that my best self is like
definitely someone who's living a
healthy lifestyle
um which is both like physically and
mentally and so i'm always kind of
working to to improve things
there and then
um
like working hard but playing hard
[Music]
you